[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt mir richtig
leckere torte und zwar das beste aus
zwei welten nämlich karriere und new
york cheesecake also sozusagen eine art
crash wie cheese cake oder kinder fähig
so wie wir das gerne wird auf jeden fall
so super lecker und wie ich schon sagte
treffen sich zwei wunderbare süßspeisen
zusammen in einer torte ich bin super
gespannt was sie sagt wir fangen jetzt
zuallererst dem zucker sirup an
und dafür benötigen wir diese vier
zutaten nämlich wasser zucker
zitronensaft und rosenwasser ich gebe zu
allererst wasser und zucker in meinem
kopf dann kann das rosenwasser auch
schon mit hinzu anschieben durch das
kurzum lasse aufkochen
[Musik]
sobald das zuckerwasser einmal aufkocht
geben wir den zitronensaft hin zu lassen
dass fünf weitere minuten köcheln
[Musik]
nachdem fünf minuten ist der zucker
sirup fertig jetzt will ich ihn kurzum
und dann zeige ich euch die zutaten für
unseren kreis boden für den boden
benötigen wir cardiff das ist dieses
engelshaar diese ganz dünnem teig fehlen
die findet ihr in jedem türkischen
arabischen supermarkt und außerdem
geschmolzene butter
wir müssen jetzt zuallererst den cup so
ein bisschen auseinander freeman also am
besten mit den händen so und so ein
bisschen auseinander zucken
[Musik]
sobald er an alles schön auseinander
gezuckt haben seht ihr das volumen hat
sich total verdoppelt beziehungsweise
verdreifacht und jetzt geben wir die
geschmolzene butter mit dazu und hier
braucht ihr noch keinen drucker denn das
kommt später alles mit dem zucker sirup
so und jetzt nochmal richtig gut
verteilen mit den händen
[Musik]
sobald der kasse mit der butter richtig
schön vermengt wurde nehmen wir uns
unsere springform ich habe hier nur 26
cm springen zu gehen aber auch zum
beispiel 24 oder 28 und jetzt müssen wir
die springform erst mal richtig schön
einfetten
ich nehme hier ein teelöffel butter und
verstreicht das schön
[Musik]
das einfetten ist ganz wichtig damit wir
unseren boden gleich aus der form
bekommen und jetzt kommt jetzt geben wir
zwei drittel unserer kartei mischung in
die springform und drücken das schön
flach an den anderen dritte benötigen
wir später noch
[Musik]
zum andrücken könnt ihr auch einfach die
rückseite von einem glas benutzen dann
geht das ganze einfacher
[Musik]
vor der vorbereitete kaffeebohnen werdet
und vorgeheizten ofen gebacken und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder in der
zwischenzeit bereitet schon mal das
restliche drittel vorländer frauen wir
später für unsere deko und hier nehmt
euch noch irgendeine form auf reformen
oder springen vom völlig egal und fettet
die richtig ordentlich mit butter 1
und dann geben wir unser charakter ganz
locker drüber
und sobald unser kater boden aus dem
ofen kommt und fertig ist schieben wird
das hinterher
jetzt soll ich gerade meinen boden aus
dem ofen geholt der ist noch richtig
schön heiße zuckersirup ist mittlerweile
lauwarm ist auch okay wenn der kalt ist
aber lauwarm reicht vollkommen denn
jetzt gießen wir so vier bis fünf
esslöffel von dem zucker sirup auf den
heißen boden
[Musik]
dem boden müssen wir jetzt vollständig
auskühlen lassen denn wir brauchen die
vor mir noch eine zweite springform da
müssen wir unseren cheesecake noch drin
backen und wir müssen ja vorher den
boden rausholen aus der form am besten
holt ihr euch dann schon eure
tortenplatte denn sobald es aufgekündigt
zeige ich euch wie ihr das am besten
umstürzt der boden ist jetzt vollständig
außen kühl ich hatte ihn in der
zwischenzeit auch im kühlschrank jetzt
muss er nur noch irgendwie auf unsere
tortenplatte kommen und das macht ihr am
besten so indem ihr das umgedrehte
draufgehen und dann einmal komplett
umdreht und dann könnt ihr das mittel
platzieren und das komplett entfernt
jaha magic so das ist noch mal gut
gegangen weil mit cardiff ist es
wirklich so eine sache denn eigentlich
ist ja nicht dafür gemacht dass man den
von irgendwo anders hin transportiert
aber so sieht der boden ganz gut aus so
gebe ich mir dann die seite und dann
mache ich weiter mit dem cheesecake
freut zeige ich euch aber noch mal ganz
kurz was aus dem anhang geworden ist
also hier müsst ihr kein zucker sirup
drauf geben das machen wir erst ganz zum
schluss dass es für die deko und kommt
auch an die seite für den new york
cheesecake benötigen wir doppel rahmen
frischkäse außerdem creme fraiche zucker
ein wenig mehl den saft einer halben
zitrone und vanille extrakte die
zubereitung ist total unkompliziert wir
geben alle zutaten in eine schüssel und
verrühren dass ich nehme ich heute mal
mein handwerk gerät es geht sogar mit
einem schneebesen also bräuchte tier
noch nicht mal ein elektronisches gerät
so einmal im doppel rahmen frischkäse
sein creme fraiche und creme fraiche
könnt ihr auch gerne durch schmandt
ersetzen
und dann gebe ich auch noch den zucker
vanille extrakt und den saft der zitrone
rein
[Musik]
nachdem das ganz kurz miteinander
verrührt wurde geben wir nach und nach
die eier mit dazu
[Musik]
so und jetzt gehen wir noch das meer mit
hinzu und so schnell ist der teig für
den new york cheesecake fertig
[Musik]
den fertigen käse kuchenteig gebe ich
jetzt immer eine vorbereitete spring
punkt das ist dieselbe wie vor hin
die habe ich mit backpapier ausgelegt um
den ofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt
auf 150 grad ober und unterhitze
[Musik]
der new york cheesecake wurde von mir
gebacken 45 minuten lang und er ist
jetzt vollständig ausgekühlt am besten
gibt ihnen sogar für vier stunden den
kühlschrank
ich weiß es dauert ein bisschen aber wir
müssen ihn jetzt aus der form rausholen
und irgendwie auf unseren boden geben so
jetzt zeige ich euch mal gelöst
zuallererst von der springform
[Musik]
am besten geht das natürlich auch somit
orten retter und vergisst nicht das
backpapier und runter zu entfernen und
jetzt nehme ich mit meinen boden der war
auch in der zwischenzeit im kühlschrank
so und jetzt gehen wir einfach den
käsekuchen auf den boden
[Musik]
jetzt fehlt nur noch die deko und dafür
nehmen wir die übrig gebliebenen teils
sehen und geben dir einfach unregelmäßig
auf die torte
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der restliche
zuckersirup auf die teig sehen
und damit wir jetzt noch ein bisschen
farbe die torte kriegen gebe ich dann
auch richtig schöne grüne pistazien
drauf
[Musik]
ich hoffe jetzt natürlich dass er diesen
king of skate fleißig nach macht oder
karachi skate ich weiß ich kann mich
ganz so richtig entscheiden wie ich den
nennen soll kinder fertig oder karachis
kick schreibt mir mal eure tipps in die
kommentare ich kann den titel ja immer
noch ändern
und ansonsten stehen wir immer in der
infobox alle genauen mengenangaben ich
freue mich wie immer über eure fotos auf
insider mit dem hashtag ekis kitchen
falls sie noch nicht folgt schnell rüber
aber sofort und hier sollte dem ich
natürlich auch abonnieren dem tier kein
video mehr verpasst und ich sag bis zum
nächsten mal auf geht s kitchen
[Musik]